en medio de las explosiones
un soldado ucraniano detiene un auto y
ayuda a subir a una mujer vida aquí en
lysychansk las fuerzas rusas y
ucranianas liberan una batalla de
artillería casas y vehículos estallan en
llamas
la ciudad de cerca severodonezk y el
objetivo actual del avance ruso aquí se
cree que hay cientos de personas
bloqueadas dentro de esta planta química
el sábado el gobernador regional dijo
que el bombardeo de la infraestructura
ha causado un incendio y una fuga de
aceite según los separatistas apoyados
por moscú 300 a 400 soldados ucranianos
están dentro mientras quiera afirma que
hay 800 personas incluyendo civiles
el ejército ucraniano y miembro de los
batallones nacionalistas siguen en la
zona industrial en la planta de ashdot
desde donde bombardean la ciudad no
podemos actuar fuertemente allí porque
es una infraestructura industrial
química
chevron y as ilicic an son las últimas
zonas del este de la región de luhansk
que todavía están bajo control ucraniano
en el sur del país las fuerzas de moscú
que ocupan la ciudad de carson se vieron
distribuyendo pasaportes rusos a los
residentes una medida es desestimada por
el presidente de ucrania
entre los residentes había colaboradores
y gente del entorno ruso no aparecía una
fila para obtener pasaporte sino más
como una tentativa para salir es muy
revelador
bueno de mier selenski dijo que las
fuerzas ucranianas han empezado a
reconquistar partes de la región de
carson y que estaban ganando terreno en
sa por día